vamos a suponer que tenemos la siguiente
sucesión uno menos un medio después un
tercio después menos un cuarto después
un quinto y esta expresión sigue y sigue
y sigue y sigue muy bien creo que más o
menos ves cómo está definida esta
sucesión y sería muy bueno graficar la
de una vez así que déjame poner aquí
mira de leyes y por acá voy a poner a mi
eje de las bueno en este caso no es x es
n va a ser mi eje de las n porque lo que
estoy haciendo es variando a n en los
naturales y aquí está el 1 aquí va a
estar el menos uno y bueno aquí está el
menos un medio aquí está en un medio y
entonces voy a poner valores para n pero
como n existe unos naturales entonces
aquí está n igual a 1 esta base el 1
aquí está el 2 por acá va a estar el 3
por aquí el 4 por aquí el 5 y así sigue
y sigue muy bien y ahora vamos a poner
los correspondientes puntos cuando n
vale 1 ya toma el valor de 1
en darle una toma el valor de 1 esto es
lo que nos dice el primer dato de esta
sucesión es decir podemos decir que ya
es igual a n y bueno cuando en el d2
llegó la sucesión vale menos un medio
por lo tanto cuando el cne vale 2
entonces la sucesión vale menos un medio
que está como por aquí y ahora cuando n
vale 3 llévale un tercio un tercio está
muy cerca de aquí por aquí está un
tercio y bueno cuando n vale 4 llegó la
sucesión vale menos un cuarto por lo
tanto estamos más pegados al eje de las
en estamos como por aquí y después
cuando n vale 5 y vale un quinto y un
quinto va a ser más o menos este valor
de aquí y después podemos seguir y
seguir y seguir y seguir lo que quiero
que te des cuenta es que estos puntos
están saltando alrededor del eje de la
cen es y se van acercando más y más y
más y cada vez más al cero y esto me
lleva a preguntarme qué es lo que va a
pasar con esta sucesión cuando n tiende
a infinito y es justo lo que quiero
resolver en este
vídeo es decir dicho en otras palabras
esto es lo mismo que pensar el límite de
esta sucesión cuando n tiende a infinito
estas dos expresiones son equivalentes y
bueno para esto estaría muy bien
encontrar una expresión para esta
sucesión vamos a ver si podemos
encontrar la fórmula de esta sucesión y
bueno para esto es recuerda que todas
las sucesiones se ven como las hacen es
desde n igual a 1 este infinito en
recorriendo los números naturales con la
siguiente regla de correspondencia a n
quien es y bueno a primera vista parece
exceder que es lo mismo que 1 entre n es
lo primero que te das cuenta sin embargo
los signos están alternando y bueno para
que los signos estén entrenando lo que
hay que hacer es multiplicarlo por menos
uno elevado a qué potencia y si tú
quisieras que esta sucesión se alternará
empezando con un signo negativo tendrás
que poner una n arriba sin embargo como
empezamos con un signo positivo tenemos
que poner una n 1 y de hecho te lo
puedes verificar por ejemplo cuando el
cne vale 1
aquí me queda 1 entre 1 que es 1 x menos
1 al cuadrado pero menos unos cuadrados
uno y uno por uno es 1 por lo tanto creo
que si funciona esto
regla de correspondencia es decir que
esto es lo mismo que menos 1 elevado a
la n 1 entre n cuando hago la
multiplicación de quebrados y por lo
tanto este límite de aquí lo puedo
escribir como el límite de menos 1
elevado a la n 1 entre n cuando n tiende
a infinito y yo sé que no hemos definido
de manera formal que es esta expresión
del límite sin embargo de una manera
intuitiva tú te puedes dar cuenta que
esto se está acercando y acercando y
acercando al 0 pues tiene toda la lógica
del mundo menos 1 elevado a la n 1 lo
que hace es dar los valores positivos
negativos positivos negativos y n tiene
infinito por lo tanto que estamos
dividiendo un 1 o un menos uno entre un
número muy muy muy muy grande y esto
quiere decir que esta expresión es una
expresión muy pero muy pero muy pequeña
entonces el límite cuando n tiene
infinitos de esta expresión se está
aproximando a 0 y bueno realmente
todavía no hemos probado este límite
pero si esto fuera cierto si esto fuera
cierto entonces puedo decir la siguiente
expresión y déjenme anotarlo por aquí si
esto es cierto entonces puedo decir lo
siguiente entonces puedo decir que la
sucesión
converge al 0 convergen al 0 y bueno
esto sí es cierto si demostramos que
este límite realmente es igual a cero si
esto no fuera cierto es decir si el
límite cuando n tiende a infinito de una
sucesión no se aproxima a cierto valor y
ojo no forzosamente tiene que ser igual
a cero puede ser igual a cualquier
constante pero bueno si esto no pasa y
pese a que todavía no he definido bien
esta idea del límite si esto no pasa
entonces decimos que la sucesión a n
divergen